all right you've made your prediction
and we've tied a tennis balls at the
base of the slinky here and now we're
going to extend it and drop it and see
what happens to the tennis ball the
heavy weight of the tennis ball is going
to stretch the spring a little bit
further so I'm going to cheat a little
bit by shortening it a fraction at the
top all right so we can see both the top
and bottom ends it sounds good and on
the count of three I'll drop it ready
one two three
whoa what did you see there that felt
very rapidly I need to look at that in
slow motion to see what's going on all
right let's go to the slow-motion
footage
[Music]
so when you watch that you see that the
tennis ball it really remains stationary
until the whole slinky is collapsed
above it correct that the white force
acting on the tennis ball is countered
by the tension force acting upwards
until the information travels down the
slinky that the tension has changed it's
really quite strange because it's as
though the falling slinky can support
the tennis ball in a way that's what it
looks like I hate that's what it's doing
I just find that so amazing and so
counterintuitive we study physics
because lots of unexpected things happen
and as those unexpected things that make
physics interesting it's it's really
strange it's like you're falling out of
a plane you had a big enough slinky you
might be okay for a little while I
wouldn't try it though you're better off
with a parachute exactly all right well
thanks rod much appreciated your your
help today
it's been fun